and trump scoring a major legal victory
that's got the media fuming a federal
judge in florida granting trump's
request to a special master to review
the items seized during the fbi raid on
mar-a-lago some in the media media not
too happy about that and lashing out at
the judge trump judges do not believe in
the rule of law they do not believe in
president do not believe in facts they
do not believe in logic it is striking
how this judge has created this
exceptions it's it's a wild decision
this is the most important professional
thing that this judge has ever done in
her life and you'd expect an a-game and
this is riddled with errors and
silliness and before we hear any
commentary from here i want you to
listen to one more this is msnbc host
maddie hassan with a interesting theory
the rest of the world is probably
wondering why he hasn't been prosecuted
yet
why we are a weird global outlier when
it comes to giving former leaders some
kind of blanket immunity from
prosecution okay so you had that's a
roundup of what was going on judge what
do you think about the judge's decision
to
allow for a special master you know i i
really wasn't surprised because she had
indicated she was inclined to do it she
asked the government what is the harm to
a special master and she said that
this special master which she will
select i think at the end of the week
based upon input by both the department
of justice
as well as president trump's attorneys
this special master will have to go
through 11 000 plus documents and that
person may be alone and not necessarily
have his own team of people like the
government but what she's basically
saying here is that um that there has
been enough of a callous disregard by
the fbi of the president and and there's
a good there's a good argument for that
in terms of the fisa warrant the
re-upping of the warrant and all of the
russia collusion delusion so she said
you know what i'm not going to rely on
the doj's team to review this and we
already know the doj's team took
attorney-client stuff but she did
something really important what she said
was in addition to attorney client i
want them to kind of filter through and
see if there's anything that's that's
protected by executive privilege there
are also medical records and tax records
i mean this is beyond the scope of the
search based upon the warrant itself and
there's one more thing i want to say
she quotes the united states i believe
the supreme court where a former
president must be able to successfully
invoke presidential communications
privilege for communications that
occurred during his presidency even if
the current president doesn't uh support
that that is that is opposite to what
people like bill barr is saying you know
executive privilege doesn't apply it's
not a hundred percent settled but there
is case law to the effect that you can
uh uh protect that information and
that's what she's hoping the special
master will do
jesse one of the liberal commentators uh
talked about the judge's decision being
a breathtaking overreach which is what a
lot of people were saying about that
support president trump that that was a
breathtaking overreach to raid
mar-a-lago
so the judge biden shot the warrant to
fair and balanced judge this guy donated
to obama he's an epstein team lawyer
he's posting political streets on the
internet he's recusing himself because
he has trump derangement syndrome but a
federal judge
confirmed by the senate
almost half the senate democrats voted
for this judge to confirm her leahy
voted to confirm feinstein voted confirm
pristine record
why
because a democratic president raided
the home of a republican president so
she says let's have an independent guy
come and look and sort this whole thing
out the american people see that that's
the fair thing to do special master i
kind of like the ring of that don't you
greg i want to be a special master right
you've been very bad jessica
you've been really bad i think that i'm
going to punish you i know i kind of i'm
not into the whole thing too
if you if you look at the media
commentary on this judicial ruling you'd
think she took a sharpie and wrote let's
go brandon on a piece of paper who's
like here
like no it was a very it was a very
thoughtful ruling yeah
harold is there any nuance here
well
let me say i agree with the former
prosecutor this is that this is a big
win for for president trump
um
it'll likely i think delayed the the uh
investigation which um i don't know who
that favors i've heard commentary that
it probably favors president former
president trump more than anything else
um it was interesting to me judge that
she cited um this judge cited the
reputation of the president and her
concern for the reputation i mean any
criminal defendant who was investigated
um
you would be he or she would be
concerned about their reputation if they
were innocent and i've never seen the
court quite give that kind of deference
it almost i'm i'm just not a believer in
special treatment for any woman bill
clinton was president he was a sitting
president they deposed him uh ken starr
did so this idea of special treatment is
not something i i really really agree
they didn't break into this house well
they didn't they broke they didn't break
into a country club either they got a
court approved warrant to go in there
and the reason they did judge which gets
to my fourth point the president still
what i found amazing
is that former president trump still has
not explained
why he defied a subpoena first of all
why he took the documents why he defied
the subpoena uh and if indeed he was
doing something with the documents
saying he needed i've heard people
speculate he might have been writing a
book and other things these are all
legitimate things i just wish if i had
taken documents i'd say i didn't take
them or i don't know what they're what
they're doing the one the one positive
about the judge's decision is that she
is allowing the dni investigation to go
forward around the damage assessment of
what was there to ensure that we haven't
compromised any sources we haven't
compromised any other collection efforts
so i don't know what the justice
department's going to do if they're
going to appeal or not uh but it
certainly is a win for for president
trump let me turn the floor over to you
well if i were a special master i would
get this done in an hour the most
obvious explanation is that when you
move out like you know you break up
split up stuff gets put in boxes your ex
calls and says you took my sweatshirt
right my bu sweatshirt you have my tone
loch cds you have my favorite wine
glasses and you go no i didn't yes you
did because i know that they're missing
no i swear to god i didn't take your
wine glasses oh no you took your wine
glasses and then you go and you find out
that maybe you did and now they're
broken and you don't want to say
anything so this is mo this is more
about dividing stuff up right it's like
figuring out what belongs
but even more you know what this reminds
me of you know when you watch your
favorite sitcom or drama there's like
three story lines and there's always one
you hate because like in 24 they always
had oh maybe the secretary has an
interesting life no she doesn't or
france phoebe's brother shows up but
it's like why do we have why do they
even have phoebe anymore on the show
because that story line always goes to a
dead end
these tangents are not the main story
about what's going on in america this is
what in cable news is like a tertiary
narrative that takes you out somewhere
else and then drops you off there and
doesn't and then when the story goes
away doesn't bother to drive you back
we've been through this a million times
you know what i'm saying it's like this
thing that like it just like
and then you like you listen to it
you're going
what are we talking about we're talking
about papers
best tone log song
ah oh geez the one with the the one that
samples van halen funky called medina
that's pretty good
wild thing by the way r.i.p
tone lopes yeah all right
all right
all right
rip to this block hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else